hey this is really funny bill o'reilly
sort of trying to make a comeback after
being completely disgraced on fox news
last week bill o'reilly played up his
anger where he sort of like is
frustrated with his scripts and looks at
pretending to rip them up and he was
flipping out because of minorities and
gang violence and who the hell knows
what
he now
is offering a service
it's a concierge program
where if you have travel questions for
bill
if you have a problem with a product or
an airline has stiffed you or left you
high and dry at an airport or whatever
you can contact bill
and he will give you advice
and uh this is what i should be doing
this shouldn't i uh anyway tell me if
this sounds appealing to you or if this
is just the latest grift so i get a lot
of questions about people traveling the
world yep
and i
because i've been to 84 countries i can
steer you into good places sure and tell
you if you get ripped off
is it really worth paying
12 euro a day
to rent a bike
in copenhagen if you don't know and
you're in copenhagen and you're like is
this a good price
you contact bill o'reilly and he will
tell you get questions about consumer
problems that somebody's contractor is
doing a and then i can steer them i get
financial questions i cannot give
financial or medical advice but i can
tell you what i would do right if you're
like listen bill i know you can't tell
me whether i should open a 529 account
for my kid or whether interest rates are
going i know you can't officially tell
me but what would you do in this exact
same situation
all right so life is complicated
for a concierge membership on bill
o'reilly.com you have me
to answer your questions which we do
within 24 hours right now who is we
is that the royal we i don't know what
that is that's interesting i mean
it's pretty amazing so you might want to
think about it yep definitely something
to think about now you might be shocked
to hear this
it's only
7.92 cents a month for this so
my
belief
is that bill o'reilly isn't
personally answering your questions for
7.92 a month
my guess is that
it's some lackey so you know i'm
considering a new espresso machine
maybe it's time for me to go and ask
bill o'reilly what what about us which
steam wands are the best do i need a
double boiler
uh he's the guy he's the guy that i
guess i should be asking now in all
seriousness i don't know how many people
have checked out bill o'reilly's uh
content recently it's pretty weird like
it it seems almost like a kind of
neutered bill o'reilly who has to
pretend and play up his anger i'll play
a little bit of this stuff for you
here is
the no spin news from from o'reilly
check this out uh oh no hold on a second
it's actually hard they make it hard to
find previews let's see if i can even
navigate his website no spin news watch
free excerpts let's see if we can check
that out
um
he here's a segment about
hunter biden that he did yesterday this
should be interesting let's check out
his commentary
it doesn't seem
like the hunter biden situation
it's two years
since the grand jury has been empowered
in
in delaware it doesn't take two years to
do this kind of investigation so
i'm saying that this is just phony
this whole now does he mean that it's
phony to even be investigating him or
that the investigation is a cover full
hunter biden thing how do you see it
yeah the concern i have bill is
when you have already put witnesses in
front of the grand jury
you're supposed to request that the
grand jury once they've heard from all
the witnesses
to vote on whether or not to indict and
and they put witnesses many many months
ago in front of the grand jury
so the question really is do they ever
intend to because i i've never seen it
take this long from the time they had
witnesses in front of the ground i guess
they're saying that the hunter
investigation is a sham that seems to be
the point to win the prosecutor says
okay you have the case now grand jury
now go and vote
on whether or not an indictment should
come yeah the prosecutor is a guy named
david weiss delaware's u.s attorney but
this looks phony to me all right so
there's bill so if you're looking for
hunter biden takes there's an
interesting one
let's see
if i can find oh he oh this has to be
this is going to be good
here bill provides advice if you go to
breakfast at a diner how to save some
money
so
it's really bad in america now it'll get
better but it's going to be a while and
we're going to be absorbing pain
i i can't i'm the idea of bill o'reilly
giving diner advice i am so curious what
he says money is important provides you
with security it provides you with peace
of mind don't waste money right so i'm
gonna give you tips
under the smart live banner to save
money
okay we'll do it two times a week we'll
have a lot of tips on the website if you
have tips
please send it to us and share it with
the rest of the world call it bill
o'reilly.com again
okay let us know we'll post them
okay so
uh over the weekend i took the urchins
for breakfast about i don't know a
quarter of a mile from my house
and uh he took it did he say he took the
urchins what is that like his grandkids
uh
they go in and they immediately they
order
two dollar and fifty cents orange juice
uh oh okay and bill's only worth 85
million so he's not going to stand for
that so little cup
250
tropicana i saw them pour it not fresh
squeeze
okay today i went on the internet
and
56
58 ounces of tropicana
three bucks oh this is i don't this is
the most compelling thing i've ever this
is the most interesting tv bill o'reilly
has ever done
so my urchins spend five bucks
on little cups when you can get 58
ounces and we have in the refrigerator
now does i wonder if phil o'reilly
drinks wine at restaurants because
it's hard to find something more
overpriced than that i mean it does
this is weird
we have it so it looked like oh what are
you doing
we have oj in a refrigerator what what
what is this five bucks
on fire
then
they order their entrees what they want
for breakfast and then they order a side
of corned beef hash uh oh
now the side of corned beef hash in the
place is good
but they didn't want to change the menu
prices so they cut the size in half
it's nine bucks
and why you used to get a pretty good
portion of corn beach half bill is not
getting his corned beef hash and he is
pissed you don't any longer
and they didn't even eat it
this this seems like satire
this this seems like it is a joke we're
full from the pancakes and the omelet
i'm sitting here going
all right let's add it up nine bucks and
five bucks 14 bucks you just set on fire
i think bill's tip is order less food
when you go out eat less food is really
the way to save money
and they did and now the eye roll is the
eye roll
now okay
this is what i'm talking about the urges
have no blanking clue they work they
have to in my house
but dad pays the breakfast oh i guess
he's talking about his kids not even his
grandkids
but
it's that kind of waste you've got to be
thinking about
value
you got to be thinking about this now
there's two layers of this first
hearing bill o'reilly
be pissed off about the size of a corn
beef beef
corn
side
is endlessly fascinating i actually
might pay for it i'm now thinking i
might buy this subscription
uh and send questions about pizza
toppings and how to save money and you
know have them calculate the area of a
circle to tell us that the larger pizza
is usually the better deal that's
fascinating
but this is kind of like the latte
millionaire stuff this is a big thing in
the personal finance space which is like
hey listen you know if you just didn't
get your your latte
uh every day you'd be a millionaire you
know in like 17 years you'll be a
millionaire or whatever
you know the reality is that the things
that for most people are keeping them
from being financially independent or
even stable right they're just just even
stable
um
are the cost of housing cost of
transportation
stagnant wages it's it's not real like
it's fine this stuff is fine but it's
along the same lines of get rich by
skipping coffee and it's not really
representative of the financial pressure
that that is on most people but there it
is bill o'reilly fascinating fascinating
stuff there